these are these are all the
considerations and output into sitting
down and coming up with a a lasting
digital library and and keep improving
this as the tools improve I think we
could build them several machines
hundreds as as affordable as possible if
you gave me X number of dollars this
would be the challenge if you give me X
number of dollars and I had to preserve
human knowledge how many books could I
store versus how many and maybe several
libraries of books and how much could I
use that same money to build a library
that would hold pretty much everything
that we've ever had one of the problems
I have with this solution is that it's
heavily curated and we don't know what's
going to be important
the only reason Andy and I are authors
is because we bypass the curation
machine we would never have gotten
published had we not kind of broken the
rules the way we did so I I'm sad to
think about what's going to be lost a
lot of books that never have a print
edition at all they're they're
self-published in digital form and it
might be the best thing ever written 500
years from now and and if we don't save
everything we'll lose those these are
basic things that we're going to need
you guys have done some of this with the
Rosetta project how to get this stuff
out of the machines I think like
projection to me is the most obvious to
have something that you can read without
having to have moving parts something
very robust but the ability to project
to display on the device and maybe even
to print copies they have this espresso
book machine now it's about the size of
a large printer and it pops out a
fully-formed book well that survived
10,000 years I don't know but maybe we
can look into making it robust enough to
survive a thousand so that as soon as
things go to hell as long as I've kept
it maintained it'll last long enough to
get to bridge the gap I think all of
this should be open source I think we
should definitely do the time stamp
thing I love that idea and I think it's
office we crowd-sourced one thing you
could do for instance with the long now
foundation is create a thumb drive that
had what you thought was important maybe
as much of this is in copyright or
public domain I would give you the
rights to have my digital edition on
there and sell them to people make
enough to have a profit to support the
the long now foundation but then
everyone has you know then you have tens
of thousands of copies of these thumb
drives out there which improves the
chances that we find these things and
you can plug it into your computer
anytime you want and it'll do an update
you know refresh it
[Music]
you